foreign
Ben Affleck and Jennifer Lopez make a
date night out of a work event and prove
they are very much still in the
honeymoon phase what can I tell you
we're just having a good time on Monday
night the lovebirds attended the LA
premiere of Ben's new flake The Flash
locking lips for all the photogs on the
red carpet
for real it was PDA City population
beniver is just a dream come true true
to form the two looked Chic Jen rocking
a gown from Gucci's 2023 Resort
collection Ben complimenting his wife's
look in an all-black suit and matching
shirt of course the triple threat was
there to support her man who's reprising
his role as Batman in the film if you
were to go into the past
you have no idea what the consequences
can be Bruce I could fix things you
could also destroy everything I got like
a little bit of cool bandwidth now
because being Batman and naturally Jen
is Ben's biggest cheerleader
that makes me so happy back in March she
joined her man at the premiere of his
movie air posing on the red carpet and
documenting all the behind the scenes
Deets on Instagram like Ben signing
autographs for fans and having a sweet
moment with his longtime bestie and
co-star Matt Damon you got a name for it
Air Jordan
I don't know
seriously maybe it'll grow on me what is
the magic between you and Ben I think it
mostly comes from me I would say no I
don't know we grew up together uh we see
the world in a really similar way it
makes working together really easy I
feel lucky to have had a friend and
collaborator like that for this long but
the cutest moment of all Jen reaching up
and touching Ben's hand on a movie
poster it's a great date night we're
super happy and the two have a lot to be
happy about home is about where the
people you love are
ET recently confirmed Ben and Jen closed
escrow on a mega mansion in Beverly
Hills
yeah she might still be Jenny but the
block is looking a little different
these days
we're talking 46 000 square feet 12
bedrooms and 24 bathrooms it's like a
whole nother level the price tag 60
million dollars it was worth it seems
safe to say these two who tied the knot
last August are the picture of wedded
bliss what's the best part of this
chapter and and being married to Ben
there's so many things I mean I I
couldn't you don't have enough time
right now anyway
[Music]